in this video i'll show you the rarest
animal crossing villagers using
stats to back it up
believe it or not there are certain
villagers that are statistically
more rare than others is it raymond it's
raymond right
well it's complicated you see there are
397
total villagers for animal crossing new
horizons so you're probably thinking
well one divided by 397
equals roughly a point two five percent
chance you'll obtain the one specific
villager you're looking for
right there's actually a specific way
the game calculates which villagers
you'll meet when visiting nook miles
islands and new horizons
we'll start with the most common easy to
find villagers and then work our way up
to the rarest villagers in the game
now before we get too far into the math
we need to remove the six
sanrio villagers which were recently
added to the game but only through
amiibo cards
so that leaves us with 391 and in
addition to amiibo cards there are three
other ways for you to get some of those
villagers on your island the first
method is by inviting a villager staying
at your campsite to move in
the other two methods are both dependent
upon you having an open plot of land for
a new villager when you have an open
plot you can actually just
do nothing that's right do absolutely
nothing the game will automatically move
in a new villager after a few days
this villager will be pulled from an
unseen move-in queue
and unfortunately we don't really know
how villagers get added to this
queue there's quite a bit of speculation
online that it's somehow tied to
villagers you meet on your friends
islands but then
what if you don't have any friends now
most players prefer not to sit around
and wait for the game to automatically
choose your next resident
enter villager hunts visiting islands
using nook miles tickets has finally
given fans of the series at least some
control over which villagers move in
they're by far one of the most popular
activities for players and new horizons
i mean just look around on youtube and
you'll find tons of videos with players
searching for their dream villagers
but just how good or bad are your odds
of landing the villager you want
welp let's just say i don't think you're
gonna be happy
let's get started with the most common
villagers in animal crossing new
horizons which just so happens to be
any villager in the sisterly category at
a 4.17
chance the reason for that is because
the game will always start
each island with the same two types of
villagers one female sisterly villager
and one male jock villager there are
only 24 sisterly villagers in the entire
game so your chances of getting the
specific one you want when starting out
for the first time
is 1 in 24 or 4.17
there are 56 male jock villagers so your
chances of getting the specific villager
you want there
is one in 56 or 1.79 percent
now these numbers may actually seem
pretty low but considering the vast pool
of villagers remember
391 these are actually the highest odds
we'll see
in today's video oh trust me they're
gonna get much
much lower quick tip here for starting
the game though if you have a specific
male jock villager or
female sisterly villager that you want
on your island
your absolute best chance of getting
them is right from the start if you
don't get them you can actually reset
your game pretty early
just follow these steps start the game
and watch the scene where you see the
first two villagers
at the airport if you're not satisfied
reset by pressing the home button and
closing out of the game
then restart the game and repeat the
above steps until you're satisfied the
odds on those villagers drop
quite dramatically after the initial
start of the game so if there's one of
those that you're really really hoping
for your best chance is gonna be right
there
at the beginning okay now it's time to
prepare yourself anytime you visit a
nook miles island while having an open
plot of land the game will place a
villager on that island for you to talk
to
and invite to your island if you wish
but just how does it calculate which
villager you'll see the game will first
select a species and there are 35
species and new horizons which means
each one has a 2.86
chance of appearing so the odds there
are exactly the same
across the board but after the game
selects the species it will then
randomly select
one of the villagers from within that
species and with new horizons the number
in each
varies drastically there are only three
octopi which is why the odds of finding
the specific
octopus you want are the highest of any
villager in the game
you simply multiply 35 times 3 which
gives you a 1 in 105 chance
or 0.95 percent of getting the octopus
you're after
now there are actually some proven
mathematical ways to
increase your chances of getting certain
villagers and that's dependent upon who
you already have on your island
i'll make sure to cover that after we go
through the full list here moving on
from the octopi though the next
most likely to appear villagers are one
of the four cows
your odds of seeing the specific cow you
want are 1 in 140 or
0.71 next up we have rhinos and bulls at
1
in 210 or 0.48 percent notice we're
already seeing
significant drops as we move down the
list here
alligators anteaters hippos lions and
tigers all have 7 villagers in each
so you'll see a 1 in 245 chance or 0.41
chance at one of those follow that up
with the hamster
kangaroo monkey and goat categories
where you'll have a 1 in 280 chance
or 0.36 percent there are nine villagers
in
each of the following species chickens
eagles
gorillas and koalas here you're looking
at a 1 in 315
chance or 0.32 percent deer and
ostriches
are one in 350 or 0.29
while wolves and elephants come in at
one in 385 or 0.26 percent
i really hope i'm not crushing your
spirits here because
we are actually gonna go much much lower
guys
we've got sheep penguins and birds at 1
in 455
or 0.22 percent and from there we
actually drop below
0.2 percent from here on out horses mice
pigs or bears are one in 525
or 0.19 percent dogs and cubs are one in
560 or 0.18
there are a total of 17 ducks which puts
them in a category
all by themselves with a 1 in 595 chance
or 0.17 and finally we've reached the
top three categories for the rarest
villagers in
animal crossing new horizons this means
your odds of landing on the specific
villager you're after from this category
are incredibly low at the third most
rare you have any among the squirrel
or frog species so if you've really been
struggling to find marshall
well here's why your chances of landing
on the villager you want there are 1
in 630 or 0.16 percent
at number two we're actually looking at
the rabbit species with odds of one out
of every
700 or 0.14 percent and finally atop
our list we have the rarest villagers in
all of animal crossing and that
is any of the cat villagers there are 23
cats in total which puts them at the
most populous species in the game
23 cats times 35 species means you have
a
1 in 805 chance or 0.12
for landing on the cat you won so it's
actually not just
raymond here it's any of these cats
simply because there are so
many of them we're not done here just
yet though because there are actually
some very important caveats that will
affect your odds and make them different
from what i just read
first up you have the move-in q which i
mentioned earlier this
factors in as well but since it's a
hidden mechanic it's really difficult
for us to
include that in the math here
unfortunately if you
have a villager that is in this unseen
move in queue it's unlikely they'll
ever appear on your villager hunts and
the only way to find this is really by
trial and error and a whole lot of nook
miles tickets
korramora actually has a video up on
this that goes into a lot more detail so
i'll link that in the description below
but here we also need to take into
account which villagers you
already have on your island all of those
numbers we just ran through
assume there are no villagers on your
island and obviously that's not the case
so instead your specific odds will be
different based on who you already have
on your island so let me show you how to
calculate this for yourself based on the
villagers you already have and also give
you a few tips for how you can actually
improve your odds of getting certain
villagers okay let's say that i'm
looking for
lucky on my next villager hunt there are
16 dogs overall so if we multiply 16 by
35 we get a one out of 560 chance that
our next villager hunt will result in
lucky but what if i already have cherry
and say biscuit on my island
both cherry and biscuit are obviously
dogs and considering you can't get
duplicate villagers that would actually
lower the number of possible dogs from
16 to 14.
so instead of multiplying 16 by 35 as we
did before we would actually multiply
14 by 35 which puts us at a slightly
improved 1 in 490 chance of getting
lucky
see what i did there wouldn't it be
great if there were ways to
up your chances of getting the villager
you want well here's where it gets
really interesting because you could
actually increase your odds of getting
lucky by hoarding as many other dog
villagers as you can
you see what happens is because it will
keep lowering the total number of dogs
available within that species that means
that number that you multiply by 35 is
going to get lower and lower
now i recognize for some people this is
just not going to be feasible because
you may not want to get rid of certain
villagers or
take in villagers that you really don't
want but let's say you're someone who is
really wanting a specific cat villager
for example then your odds of finding
the one you want
actually go up the more cats you can get
on your island now you can further
increase your odds if you had
all of a certain species this would
actually up it even more
unfortunately this is probably only
feasible with the lower number ones like
the cow
or the octopus but let's say for example
you were to have all four cows on your
island that would actually remove
one of the 35 species and lower it to
34.
so then when you do the little
multiplication there you're going to be
multiplying by 34 rather than 35.
honestly though the best way to increase
your chances of getting the villagers
you want is by having
lots of friends who also play animal
crossing this can take a lot of
coordination but basically if your
friend has a villager moving out and you
have an open plot
you can visit that friend's island and
invite the villager to move to your
island instead
of course guys make sure you fact check
me as well this was a lot of math so if
i got one of these calculations wrong i
definitely want to know about it
so now that you know the odds which
villager are you going after next
let me know in the comments below if
you're new to animal crossing i have a
full beginners playlist filled with tips
and tricks to help you get started with
the game
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon